na war das schön was wir da am Mittwoch
hinter unserem Türchen gefunden haben
einen ampelhaushalt ja sie haben sich
doch noch geeinigt gut es war jetzt
nicht der ganz große Wurf und viele
Fragen sind auch noch völlig offen z.B
wie sich das alles rechnet und ob
überhaupt aber es ist ein Haushalt die
Ampel rettet sich also vorläufig
mindestens bis ins nächste Jahr und was
brachte den Durchbruch ich kann es ihnen
sagen dass dem Kanzler plötzlich etwas
Erstaunliches klar geworden ist wir
müssen mit deutlich weniger Geld
auskommen um diese Ziele zu erreichen
priorisieren heißt deshalb miteinander
zu klären was wir uns leisten können und
was
nicht hör doch auf man kann nur ausgeben
was man hat ja ich meine er denkt sich
einen buchungstrick aus fliegt damit auf
die Fresse und jetzt erklärt er uns was
priorisieren heißt danke dafür ich
wusste das schon ja in diesem Jahr
bringen die heiligen drei Könige also
Mürre Weihrauch und einen höheren CO2
Preis ja ja sie freuen sich richtig ne
ja das ist klimapolitisch schon richtig
nur müsste man das natürlich sozial
abfedern mit dem sogenannten klimageld
sie erinnern sich das sollte uns Bürgern
zurückgegeben werden jetzt kann sich
keiner mehr dran erinnern ne
andererseits kann die Ampel ja gar
nichts für die CO2 Preiserhöhung das war
alles die groco mit ihrem blöden
wir kehren auf den alten preisfahrt
zurück zu dem fahr den die letzte
Bundesregierung der ich auch angehört
habe bereits beschlossen hatte auf den
CO2 Fahrt der groko auf den preisfahrt
der großen Koalition auf den Fahrt der
großen Koalition auf ein Fahrt zurück
zurück auf den preisfahrt auf den Fahrt
der großen Koalition zurück na das ist
spannende
Sache ja am Ende war meistens die
Merkel so kann man sich merken haben die
drei hier noch einen Kompromiss Zustande
gekriegt irgendwie weil alle ein
bisschen bluten mussten gut am meisten
natürlich wie immer der Harbeck der ist
es gewohnt ja ich sag mal dass der
trotzdem weiter in dieser toxischen
Beziehung bleibt da muss ich sagen
Respekt oder das nötigt mir schon
Respekt
ab ja überlegen Sie mal das meiste Geld
holen Sie aus Roberts
klimatransformationsfond von insgesamt
65 Milliarden klimaschädlichen
Subventionen die wir vor Jahr pro Jahr
verballern werden gerade mal 3
Milliarden eingespart z.B die für
Agrardiesel also Diesel an sich wird
fröhlich weiter subventioniert nur nicht
der für Trecker und Inlandsflüge kosten
dann auch bald mehr ist do völlig klar
was jetzt passiert das Hamstern geht
wieder los frohes
[Musik]
Fest Papa ist das die Playstation 5 kann
sein mach doch mal auf
ein Benzinkanister viel besser Agra
Diesel 5 l da werden deine Freunde in
der Schule aber Augen
machen ist das bei mir auch Diesel ja
klar das nicht dein Ernst was meinst du
was der nächstes Jahr Wert
ist das ist alles Diesel so Leute pack
die Koffer wir fliegen die weihnachtsf
nach Paderborn was wieso nach padaborn
weil Inlandsflüge ab Januar teurer
werden lie doch einmal die Zeitung du
blöde Kuh
Abmarsch vielen Dank Olaf
[Musik]
Scholz
ja es hilft ja nichts
ne was sollen sie
machen ich sag mal wenn man keine
Steuern erhöht und die Schuldenbremse so
bleiben muss dann zahlen wir halt
woanders drauf ne beim Tanken und heizen
z.B Spiel der Grundkonflikt der Ampel
ist nicht gelöst worden er wurde nur
verschoben vielleicht wird schon in dem
halben Jahr doch wieder die Notlage
ausgerufen wegen Atal oder Ukraine je
nachdem was ich ergibt ne hat dieser
Mann hier also noch die Kraft sein Laden
weiter zusammenzuhalten diese Bilder vom
SPD Parteitag letztes Wochenende sagen
eindeutig ja über 5 Minuten Applaus für
eine Rede von Olaf Scholz ohne dass im
Saal Drogen verteilt
wurden unglaublich Wahnsinn dabei steht
die Kanzlerpartei SPD bei erschütternden
14% trotzdem Euphorie ja regelrecht
Aufbruchstimmung beim SPD Parteitag vor
allem als sie hier am Mikro war und wenn
wir Wahlen gewinnen wollen auch im Osten
Leute dann müssen wir brennen damit wir
in anderen etwas entzünden können und
nicht der Olaf und jetzt stell euch mal
vor der Olaf W so wie ich das geht
nicht warum
nicht geil oder ja Claudia Moll vor
Kanzlerin da wä ich sofort dabei sofort
ja realistischer ist aber leider ein
anderes Szenario Friedrich März ja
Friedrich März heißt unser
reservekanzler aktuell der
wahrscheinlichste CDU Kanzlerkandidat in
dieser Vorweihnachtszeit ne
also falls die Ampel doch noch
auseinander fliegt wegen weiß ich nicht
Asylpolitik oder wie immer ihr nächstes
Streitthema heißt es kommt ja garantiert
die CDU ist jedenfalls bereit sagt die
CDU seit dieser Woche sogar Bereiter
denn je denn sie haben Achtung ein neues
Grundsatzprogramm ja ihr erstes seit
2007 herzlichen Glückwunsch ja
ein erster Entwurf liegt nun vor und wie
sagt der Generalsekretär völlig zurecht
wir brauchen wieder eine
Erkennungsmelodie mit einer
Erkennungsmelodie dass wir auf der einen
Seite eine Erkennungsmelodie wieder
haben eine unverwechselbare
Erkennungsmelodie was ist die
wiedererkennungsmelodie dieser Partei
und einer zukunftsmelodie für das
Deutche das hat die nationalhü nicht
verdient meine Damen und Herren ja so
aber was steht drin im CDU
Programmentwurf grundsatzprogrammentwurf
kannst ihnen sagen wir alle sollen im
Alter länger arbeiten das kann man jetzt
doof finden ist aber immer in ein Ansatz
während die Ampel das rententhema
einfach ignoriert außerdem ist die gute
alte leidkultur zurück Zitat Muslime die
unsere Werte teilen gehören zu
Deutschland müsste man dann eigentlich
für alle Religionen fordern aber das
haben sie wahrscheinlich vergessen dafür
steht ein soziales Pflichtjahr drin für
die faule Genie im Grunde wer Pflicht
nur ohne wer kurz gesagt die
Parteiführung will der CDU endgültig die
Merkel austreiben das ist offensichtlich
der Plan meine Damen und Herren ja ja
austreiben also die die
Willkommenskultur und
atomausstiegsmerkel weil mit der hat man
ja gerade mal vier Wahlen gewonnen und
mit März schon das weiß ich jetzt gar
nicht ist ja auch nicht der Punkt
vergesst Merkel mit März geht die CDU
programmatisch nur noch nach vorne
zurück in die
90er Feier jetzt die geilste Zeit deines
erbärmlichen boomerlebens die CDU 90er
Hits voller
partykracherw
echt stark diese Scheibe ist wirklich
CDU pur und zwar pur
mit schwing ein letztes mal deine
künstliche Hüfte Party
1999 und WN MC
endgültig beendet den sie ist
weg die CDU sie ist mein allein
die die CDU 90er Hits es war nicht alles
schlecht aber diese Musik
schon ja DJ
Fritze so aber es ist es ist tatschlich
hoch interessant am neuen grundsatzprm
der CD haben insgesamt 28 Arbeitsgruppen
über fast zwei Jahre mitgeschrieben es
gab Regionalkonferenzen eine
Mitgliederbefragung und am Ende liest
sich trotzdem wie das Tagebuch von
Friedrich März ja wirklich als wä durch
Sauerland gewandert während sein Jünger
Linnemann die Gedanken des Meisters
notiert also so liest sich das für mich
jedenfalls Karsten Linnemann der
übrigens nebenbei für einen spannenden
Trend des Jahres steht immer mehr
Politiker haben jetzt eigene Podcasts
und im im Grunde Talkshows in denen sie
sich gegenseitig interviewen das heißt
die sind gar nicht mehr angewiesen auf
die ganzen mechbergers und ners und
schon gar nicht auf irgendwen mit Medien
irgendwer mit Medien mit Friedrich
Küppersbusch ja noch hat das ZDF ja
Thomas Gotsch nicht bei Bares für rares
verramscht 80 € der Schlumpf J in die
EIF da erstahlt schon ein neuerstern am
deutschen moderatorenhimmel viele Fragen
er ist das überhaupt noch ein
herkömmlicher CDU Generalsekretär
oder schon eine KI einfach mal machen
der Podcast mit Karsten
Linnemann einfach mal machen so heißt
der neue Podcast ich weiß dass ich viele
darauf freuen ich hoffe es wird gut
Ksten Linnemann hatte eine schwere
Kindheit in ostwestfahen pderborn to be
wild wo linemann Junior erstmal
versuchte die elterliche Buchhandlung
mit selbstgemachten Büchern zu retten
nachts wurde er oft schweißgebadet wach
wenn ihm aus verersehen wieder ein neuer
Slogan für die fd eingefallen war die
machen eh was Sie wollen die ticken doch
nicht richtig ein eher dunkelmütiger
Blick des jungen Literaten auf unsere
Politik Kritiker rükten Linnemann man
muss doch auch mal wieder so Aufbruch
und nicht immer dieses negative
pessimistische das wir mal wieder
Aufbruch und nicht immer dieses negative
pessimistische Linnemann offensichtlich
KI man weiß nur noch nie wie viele er
beschreitet virtuos den schmalen Grad
zwischen einfach mal machen und einfach
mal in die Hose machen es muss ja nicht
die eigene sein einfach mal hinten
reinkriechen ja er ist einer der ganz
ganz großen Philosophen über den
wahrscheinlich noch in 200 300 Jahren
gesprochen wird er hat ja über 20 Bücher
geschrieben ich glaube ungefähr die
Hälfte davon
Bestseller fasziniert er duldet hier
Richard David Precht die erste bemannte
Darmspiegelung der Menschheit Lindemann
als Host setzt den Trend sich nicht mehr
von hergelaufenen journalistischen
fragebratz da zwischen quatschen zu
lassen der eigenpcast bei Friedrich März
vorher war das noch schief gegangen er
warb nämlich für sein Podcast mit einem
thumbnail auf dem ein weißer Mann auf
eine schwarze Frau herabschaut der Name
dann auch noch unterschlagen wurde promt
schitstorm die Union reagierte sofort
die Journalistin kam weg und nun steht
da ein weißer alter Mann der auf eine
weiße Frau herabschaut alles wieder gut
die hatte übrigens auch keinen Namen und
zwar Silvia Breer womit klar ist
Journalismus 20 das ist wenn der
Parteichef mit seiner eigenen
Stellvertreterin diskutiert dann braucht
die CDU auch nicht mehr so viel ARD und
ZDF und die anderen ziehen schon nach ja
meine Damen und Herren ich darf Sie ganz
herzlich begrüßen ein herzliches
willkommen zu einer neuen Folge hallo
und herzlich Willkommen herzlich
willkommen zurück zu meinem Videoformat
weidels Konter freigespräch heute mit
reiner Holznagel herzlich willkommen bei
amtors Anträgen ESN
die Selbstermächtigung unserer
austrainierten Talkshow mastinos bringt
zur Zeit noch so Klickzahlen irgendwo
zwischen outfluencer und sammeln Sie
Punkte Carsten linemann ist aber schon
wieder eins weiter und weiß inzwischen
manchmal selbst nicht mehr ist er jetzt
bei meberger oder ist der meberger W
interessant wie ihr das seht das muss
wenn dann in der Koalition geint werden
aber wir haben wir haben ja gerade
gezeigt dass wir dazu handlungsfähig
sind wir haben jetzt wir haben
jetzt in einer Zeit wo narzisstischer
Psychopath mit einem
kotznachrichtendienst der mächtigste
Mann der Welt werden kann sehen wir den
Homo sapiens im Augenblick seines
Scheiterns ich meine wie viele irre sind
eigentlich bei Twitter oder x nur um
sich den ganzen Tag drüber aufzuregen
was für ein behemmerter
meinungsterrortwiitter oder x geworden
ist wer sowas braucht kann er einfach
katholisch werden und das ist KI
Lindemann schon danken wir unserem
Schöpfer für eine neue Generation Mensch
der sich bald selbst interviewt dabei
autonom den rasenmad und unterwegs die
heute Show moderiert einfach mal lachen
irgendwer mit Medien mit Friederich
Küppersbusch Friederich
Küppersbusch ja meine Damen und
Herren es ist tatsächlich die Woche der
Durchbrüche nicht nur beim ampelhaushalt
nein auch beim Weltklimagipfel in Dubai
die Abschlusserklärung sei historisch
sagen die einen andere sind total
enttäuscht einigen wir uns also auf
kompromissgeburt ja es ist nein Klang
jetzt ein bisschen zu hart aber es ist
eine Absichtserklärung die Abkehr von
den fossilen Energieträger nicht der
Ausstieg netto null Emissionen bis 2050
werden angestrebt mehr war wohl nicht
drin beim Gipfel in einem Ölstaat
geleitet von einem öllobbyisten dr
Sultan aljbba findet das Ergebnis
jedenfalls
episch Generationen werden euren Namen
vielleicht nicht kennen aber sie werden
jedem einzelnen von euch zu Dank
verpflichtet
sein ja Kinder bedankt euch mal nicht
immer nur Sachen mit orangener Farbe
vollsprühen auch mal danke sagen dem
Chef der Z größten Ölfirma der Welt dr
Sultan gut immerhin immerhin werden
fossile Energien als Treiber der
Klimakrise in Dubai benannt das gilt als
Fortschritt und die Staaten der Welt
sind aufgefordert bis 2030 den Anteil
der erneuerbaren zu verdreifachen und
die Energieeffizienz zu verdoppeln man
muss auch mal die Erfolge nach vorne
schieben damit die Menschen nicht
verrückt werden in diesem Jahr kam in
Deutschland z.B über die Hälfte des
Stroms aus Wind und Sonne hat wir noch
nie und der Kanzler hat in Dubai sogar
einen eigenen klimaclub gegründet ja wie
erklärt man das so eine Art fählein
Fieselschweif für Staaten staten mit
großen klimaplänen mit ihm als Anführer
der Klima Bande hier begrüßt er gerade
alle anderen 35 Clubmitglieder einzeln
moin digy hallöchen bpöchen bonorno Mr
Porno alles cool im Pool du hier und
nicht in Hollywood gib Flosse Genosse
lange nicht gesehen und doch wieder
erkannt und so weiter und so weit es
ging Stunden seitdem ist Grippewelle in
Dubai seitdem ist Grippewelle in Dubai
Zufall ja die Ampel sieht sich weiter
als Führungsmacht beim Klimaschutz
wohlgemerkt dieselbe Ampel die uns
gerade die E-Auto Förderung streicht
deutschland ist und bleibt halt
klimaschutzvorreiter hat man auch bei
annaalena berbocks
Abschlusspressekonferenz in Dubi gesehen
bis zu vier Journalisten hingen ihr da
quasi begeistert an den Lippen ja ja so
eine Fanbase musste dir er arbeiten ist
ja klar der Klimawandel bleibt in jedem
Fall eine globale Herausforderung
deshalb führt an diesen Gipfeln auch gar
keinen Weg vorbei so klein die
Fortschritte manchmal auch sind ich sehe
schon von meinem geistigen Auge wie das
wird wenn Deutschland im Jahr 2050
Gastgeber ist und der Bundeskanzler sagt
liebe Mitbürger herzlich willkommen zur
Weltklimakonferenz 2050 hier in meiner
Heimat Mecklenburg Vorpommern auch in
diesem Jahr wird Deutschland wieder bis
zu drei neue Ladesäulen für E-Autos
bauen damit rückt das 12°ad Ziel in
greifbare Nähe und jetzt entschuldigen
Sie mich meine Mutter sagt ich soll mein
Zimmer
aufräumen ja
2050 ich freue mich
schon kleine Fortschritte aber ich meine
dabei will die große Mehrheit in
Umfragen mehr Klimaschutz also
theoretisch in der Praxis sieht's dann
schon anders aus til Reiners ist
Neurowissenschaftler und sagt echter
Klimaschutz scheitert vor allem am
menschlichen Gehirn Herr Dr Reiners das
klingt irgendwie beleidigend ja sorry
das nennt man Biologie unser Gehirn hört
seit 20 Jahren Klimakrise Klimakrise und
gewöhnt sich Hal dran deswegen sagen die
Menschen ja Klimaschutz wichtiges Thema
aber läuft uns ja nicht weg ist ja
morgen auch noch
wichtig also genau genommen sogar noch
wichtiger und übermorgen erst also so
unwichtig wie heute wird's nie
wieder ja aber wir sind nicht wir sind
doch auch auf Arterhalt programmiert
wenn sie vom Gehirn sprechen h geht's ja
sehr konkret um das Leben der
nachfolgenden Generation ja für die
interessiert sich unser Gehirn nicht das
Zeug hier oben drin interessiert sich
nur für eins mehr Dopamin die geilste
Droge der Welt kostet nichts und wir
können es selber produzieren 100% Bio
feinste wahre Dopamin wird als Belohnung
im jetzt ausgeschüttet Klimaschutz ist
Belohnung in 20 Jahren Belohnung für
unsere Kinder viele mögen ihre Kinder
aber gar nicht ja niemand rettet die
Welt weil das ein eine tolle moralische
Entscheidung ist man rettet die Welt
wenn man konkret einen Nutzen im Hier
und Jetzt hat und das langfristig auch
funktioniert also beis wenn ich jetzt
nachhaltige Bioprodukte kaufen will dann
müssen eben jetzt cool
sein ja coole Bioprodukte Klasse G unser
Gehirn kann sich nicht vorstellen dass
die Zukunft uns betrifft ich z.B saufe
gleich auf der Weihnachtsfeier der
heutehow C Kuba libre weil ich denke ich
habe heute Spaß den Kater hat ja
Zukunfts sein Problem der Idiot
zukunftstill ist für mein Gehirn ein
Fremder den kenne ich gar nicht ja aber
die Zukunft kommt ja trotzdem ja leider
ja dagegen haben wir noch nichts
erfunden außerdem sind wir auch noch der
Opfer der sogenannten Spieltheorie die
besagt solange nur die kleinste
Möglichkeit besteht dass andere ein
Problem lösen werde ich selber nichts
machen bin ja nicht blöd ist bei staten
genauso sollen die Chinesen doch erstmal
Emotionen einsparen ja ich ich kann
verstehen was sie sagen Dopamin
Spieltheorie aber der Mensch ist ja
trotzdem ein ich sag mal
vernunftbegabtes Wesen das heißt wir
können uns
ändern achso sie meinen es ernst ja okay
nee stimmt ist ja eine Comedysendung
nein die einzige Chance ist Staaten
ändern Rahmenbedingung so dass wir
Bürger aus Versehen das Richtige tun z.B
durch einen funktionierenden super
preiswerten ÖPNV also jetzt wird's ja
wirklich absurd funktionierender ÖPNV so
kein Science Fiction hier nein ich
bleibe dabei auch der Einzelne kann das
Richtige tun okay wenn das so ist wer
holen wir mal das berühmte Marshmallow
Experiment da ging es damals an der Uni
Stanford um Impulskontrolle und
belohnungs ub die Versuchspersonen waren
zwar Vorschulkinder aber bei ihnen muss
man sagen kognitiv sind sie ja
vergleichbar aufgestellt also sie
bekommen jetzt von mir eine Tüte
Gummibärchen geil Gummibärchen nee
Moment jetzt kommt ja erst das
Experiment also wenn Sie diese Tüte
extrem leckere aber dick maende
Gummibärchen bis zum Ende der Sendung
nicht essen kriegen sie noch eine zweite
Tüte dazu aber nur wenn wenn sie fertig
fertig kriege jetzt die
zweite keine weiteren
Fragen das Experiment gar nicht
verstanden ja meine Damen und Herren sie
wissen es natürlich auch es gibt bei uns
in Deutschland so viele schöne
adventstraditionen um diese Jahreszeit
behauptet z.B das halbe deutsche
Internet gern irgendwo würde Weihnachten
verboten und zwar aus falscher Rücksicht
auf Muslime und natatürlich weil wir nun
mal in einer grünwogen
weihnachtsfeindlichen Diktatur leben ne
es ist ja so es ist ja so ja ist ein
Ritual das kommt jede Weihnachten dieses
Jahr hatte seine Kita in Hamburg
erwischt die allen Ernstes auf einen
geschmückten Weihnachtsbaum verzichtet
eine festlich geschmückte Tanne kommt
hier nicht durch die Pforte im
weihnachtlich verschneiten Hamburg
trifft das auf wenig Verständnis hat das
Gefühl in Deutschland sind s alle
bescheuert geworden
du du das war eine Hamburger Kita eine
die in den letzten 10 Jahren mal einen
Baum hatte und mal nicht ansonsten aber
natürlich Weihnachten feiert auch dieses
Jahr inklusive Adventskalender und
Wichteln und jetzt raten Sie SP doch mal
wer sich instinktiv sofort an die
falsche Kita quatschmeldung dran gehängt
hat im Netz richtig Markus Söder war zu
einfach es war zu einfach und wir
schalten mal die iluppe wo Ulrich von
hesen heute die entsprechende
Weihnachtsgeschichte
liest die Weihnachtsgeschichte nach dem
Markus Evangelium also dem Markus Söder
Evangelium es begab sich aber zu der
Zeit dass in Bayern ein König regierte
der sich für nichts zu blöd war als z.B
bei Bild und Fokus mal Fake News über
eine Kita stand die den Kindern
Weihnachten angeblich verbietet da
dachte der Markus was für ein
skrupelloser Bullshit da will ich auch
mitmachen also griff der Dicke König zum
iPhone und twitterte das ist absurd zu
Weihnachten gehört ein Weihnachtsbaum
gehört er gar nicht der Baum ist ein
heidnischer Brauch den die Christen
geklaut haben aber woher sollte der
Markus das Wissen der ist ja evangelisch
und Land daher später sowieso in der
Hölle das ist ein ganz schrecklicher Ort
da laufen den ganzen Tag die tikts von
Markus
söler ich wünsche allen einen schönen
erwi he ist Weihnachten die schönste
Geschichte überhaupt ist die
weihnachtsgeschichteön
may the weihachs force with you may the
weinachs force with you denn Star Wars
gehört bekanntlich auch zur
Weihnachtsgeschichte und die Arme Kita
in Hamburg die zwar ohne Baum aber mit
Adventskranz und Geschenken ganz normal
Weihnachten feiert wird seitdem mit
Drohungen und Hassmails zugeballert plus
sehr eklige Grußbotschaften vom
Schlechtesten Gesundheitsminister aller
Zeiten also wer kein Weihnachtsbaum
aufstellen will als Kita der sollte dann
über Weihnachten auch haben um es mal
etwas salop zu formulieren ganz genau
wer den Baum verweigert muss Weihnachten
durchackern ohne Kekse so steh schon in
der es sprach der Vertreter einer
christlichen Partei die als
Weihnachtsgeschenk am liebsten das
Bürgergeld kürzen möchte eine Union die
spätestens 2025 wieder den Bundeskanzler
stellt der dann das ist mein Tipp liebe
Kinder markusder heen
wirdon ich mich jetztz ein sie m
wirklich aufhören den Kindern da Angst
zu machen ach die Kinder haben die
Wahrheit verdient außerdem ma ich das
hier nicht für die Kinder sondern um die
CSU zu schocken und wissen Sie was die
am meisten schockt Drag Queen Lesungen
in Kitas se oh nein wirklich bitte nicht
bitte
nicht hallöchen da bin ich wieder und
nun lese ich aus die heiligen drei
Königinnen folgenend dem senderstern
nach Betlehem um einem nonbinären Kind
zu ruligen ich glaube lieber nicht
Ulrich von hesen vielen
Dank hallo leute wenn ihr jetzt auf
Gefällt mir drückt und den Kanal
abonniert zeige ich euch meinen
lautesten Schrei für das menschliche
Gehör ist der zwar nicht wahrzunehmen
aber ich würde eure Hunde kurz
rausbringen okay
fertig